la danse moderne l'une des passions de
mélanie chaque samedi
elle suit son cours depuis trois ans ici
à la mjc de sens le conflit qui oppose
la structure à la ville de la concerne
pas vraiment mais comme la plupart des
mille adhérents
mélanie se pose des questions déjà finir
l'année puis si on peut continuer d
prochaine ce serait bien aussi c'est une
très bonne ambiance et une très bonne
équipe donc on est tous heureux de
danser ici pas les activités ci surtout
il ya beaucoup d'activités il ya
beaucoup de niveaux culture ya pas mal
de choses donc ce serait dommage que ça
se fête prévue de longue date les 24
heures du jour bien demander si la mjc
c'est là qu'elle est ici les activités
et la vie continue
l'ultimatum fixé par la mairie de
quitter les lieux avant ce soir ne
changera pour nous la demande de la
ville est totalement illégale
on s'est produit au tribunal
administratif de dijon donc des référés
nous ont donné raison
donc nous serons présents la semaine
prochaine dans les locaux et puis nous
assurons notre engagement prédit des
adhérents jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de la
saison
rien ne change pour ce qui concerne la
mjc la ville a saisi la justice et le
tribunal administratif de dijon doit se
prononcer mercredi
la mairie veut récupérer les 1700 mètres
carrés de locaux et municipaliser la mjc
mais sur place salariés adhérents et
sympathisants que l'on ne peut continuer
d'occuper les lieux 24 heures sur 24